nasal polyps are soft tissue growths in  the lining of your nose  they may also grow in the air-filled  spaces near your nose called sinuses  polyps may become irritated swollen or  infected they may grow large enough to  block airflow through your nose  to treat your polyps your healthcare  provider may try medications such as  antibiotics steroids spray or allergy  medicine if medications don't work your  healthcare provider may want you to have  the polyps removed this procedure is  called a nasal polyp ectomy in this  procedure the surgeon will insert a thin  tool with a camera on the end into your  nose images from the camera will be sent  to a video screen so that your surgeon  can see the polyps then your surgeon  will remove the polyps  after the procedure your healthcare  provider may ask you to use a saline  rinse and other medication to help keep  your airway open  talk to your healthcare provider to find  out more about nasal polyp ectomy